the motion is adopted on March 27th the
House passed the biggest stimulus
package in American history and included
in it was more than 350 billion dollars
for small businesses we're gonna keep
our small businesses strong and our big
business is strong and that's keeping
our country strong and our job strong
but for many small business owners it's
simply not enough blue collar very small
Main Street businesses around liza Foxx
and Michael Campbell's opened a
children's play zone in 2017 and shortly
after they expanded it to include a
co-working space Elemeno is just a few
blocks away from Congress in Washington
DC's Capitol Hill neighborhood and since
expanding it's become a one-stop shop
for families to work learn and relax
after successfully growing the business
for three years the couple had started
on plans to expand but like millions of
small business owners around the country
Liza and Michael had to close up shop in
mid-march as the corona virus pandemic
swept the country they suspended all of
their membership dues which means
there's no incoming revenue and they're
still on the hook for all of the
outgoing costs and due to the nature of
their business there was no way for them
or their four employees to work from
home now we did we already and we're
going to will yet vitally critical
that these small businesses were able to
make it through Mark Zandi is a chief
economist at Moody's Analytics there's
seven point eight million business
establishments across the United States
only 20 thousands of them have more than
500 employees so the vast majority of
business is not there aren't so-called
small business if you add up all the
jobs working at companies with your
employees it's about half of all of the
jobs in the United States so it's a big
chunk of the economy if you're less than
50 employees that accounts for roughly
25 percent of all jobs in the country if
you have less than four employees about
four and a half million of them have
fewer than poor employees so the vast
vast majority of businesses companies
out there are very very small less than
an ant or people the cares Act is
offering small businesses two things
first is something known as the Paycheck
protection program or PPP loans designed
to keep employees on payrolls for eight
weeks and that will be forgiven if
companies retain or rehire most of their
employees it also says that the loan can
be used for other costs but the caveat
is that only 25% can be used on things
like rent or utilities in order to meet
the criteria for the loan to be
reimbursed the other support offered in
the bill is the economic injury disaster
loan program and that promises up to ten
thousand dollars in grants for eligible
applicants but as Liza and Michael found
out after applying companies are only
able to receive $1,000 per each employee
half of what they were expecting while
these two programs do provide limited
relief for Elemeno the couple argues
that the aid is mainly supporting their
employees and it is not going to keep
the business alive for their workers to
return to everything you see in this pie
chart is fixed except for about three
percent that has a little bit of
variability in supplies but our rent is
this blue forty nine percent of our
monthly expenses
and that's hi we recognize that their
rent is our space in our space is our
product our payroll is an orange that's
strictly payroll that's not us as
business owners getting payments and
then the others are fixed expenses none
of those things go away even though our
door is closed so with the the
government programs that we have applied
for and hope to receive that does help
us with this payroll chun with the
orange 29% that's great because we love
our employees and we want to help them
through this tough time that also is the
only thing we had any flexibility on in
the first place so unfortunately if we
needed to we could lay off our employees
and save that 29% it doesn't help us
with the oven 71% of our fixed monthly
expenses the $10,000 economic disaster
loan advance helps would help of course
it would cover this chunk this sorted
others for less than two months at
$10,000 or it wouldn't cover even one
month a reverend
at the heart of one of liza and Michaels
complaints is who gets the money they
say it benefits companies with large
payroll costs and only provides limited
aid to cover rent and utilities which is
essential for small Main Street
businesses to survive trying to figure
out which make offering to us at the end
of the day we pass the money to our
employees and your looks company where
you don't have any employees you you
know you're not going to benefit as much
but you know for a broader macroeconomic
perspective I do think it makes sense to
be focused on workers and making sure
that you know businesses hold on to
those workers we got to avoid business
failures in bankruptcy I mean that's the
that's going to be really key because if
a lot of these businesses go out of
business they fail to go bankrupt when
employee workers want to have business
to go back to when the buyer
passes and it'll diminish our economy in
mid-april the 350 billion dollar loan
program for small businesses ran out of
money a fresh round of aid is being
negotiated by lawmakers but details are
not yet clear in the short term the
family can get by their landlord said
they could defer payment on one month's
rent plus Michael gets income from
another startup that's not been hit by
the crisis so far the immediate question
on the minds of small business owners
like lies in Michael is what the next
round of aid will do to keep their
businesses alive and support the
economic recovery guarantees can't file
chapter 11 so if the business is not
able to survive not only are we out and
out our investment business but we are
personally liable